sie alle wollen auf und davon
christine schönbächler und ihr mann
hermann sie ziehen mit ihren kindern
welche und natascha nach kanada anja
kinski und claude wegmann wollen sich in
italien eine existenz aufbauen mit dabei
ist kino der trüffel und anne kuhn und
orlando stamm geben ihrer jungen liebe
ein neues zuhause auf bali bauen sie
eine ferienanlage jennifer wettstein der
mann ali und sinnlichen sven versprechen
sich in peru eine bessere zukunft in
lima sollen ihre träume wahr werden
[Musik]
wahrscheinlich ist es die sehnsucht die
den menschen immer wieder einen
neuanfang wagen lässt die sehnsucht nach
einem leben in freiheit und ohne zwang
während die einen versuchen das glück in
kleinen portionen in ihrem alltag zu
finden
packen die anderen den alltag in große
container und suchen das glück in der
ferne von solchen menschen handeln diese
geschichten und einer von ihnen ist
harley beckstein den berner zieht es
zusammen mit seiner familie nach peru
mit seiner peruanischen frau jenny und
söhnchen sven sucht ali sein glück in
lima zeitung macht auch noch mehr
familien hast hingeht und settings
nämlich die guten zeiten für ihn meinte
nicht nur die bin ich nur alleine
bedenke neuen die familie
ich glaube schon klar ja wahrscheinlich
[Musik]
wir machen es mit liebe hass der gut
1900 tonnen betrug in bern hat ali
wettstein als haustechnik installateur
gearbeitet
in peru wird er sich als wirt und
unternehmer im familieneigenen betrieb
bewähren müssen
von morales kommt jetzt auch ein nicht
mehr ganz neue sessel
ali ist in einfachen verhältnissen
aufgewachsen während jahren hat er jeden
rappen für dieses abenteuer zur seite
gelegt
der berner börse erhofft sich im büro
ein besseres leben
jennys familie gehört dort zur gehobenen
gesellschaft
[Musik]
hey ihr heimatland auf wiedersehen in
peru
im engadin bei den schönen und reichen
leben 2 die ebenfalls weg wollen
[Musik]
bringst mich braucht wo die liebe ist da
ist das paradies an iq und orlando
stammen haben demnach die letzten vier
jahre im garten eden verbracht denn seit
vier jahren sind sie ein paar
[Musik]
vor drei monaten haben anni und orlando
auf der götter insel bali mit dem bau
einer hotelanlage begonnen
jetzt stehen sie kurz vor der abreise in
den ewigen sommer
[Musik]
die fantastische natur also alles so
bestätigt wie so oft packen und
konzentrieren
orlando statt arbeitete fast sein leben
lang als vermessungsingenieur aniko
hauswirtschaftslehrerin und mutter die
letzten monate wohnten die beiden im
engadin in einer gegend also die für
viele menschen das ziel aller träume ist
gesteht sie verlassen freunde familie
ihre kinder
[Applaus]
als ich sie haben nachher
ich freue mich wahnsinnig zum gau und
ich habe schon mal das abschieben
trotz der tränen überwiegt das glück der
liebenden
denn die geschichte von anni und orlando
ist die geschichte zweier menschen die
weite umwege gehen mussten bis sie
zueinander fanden
[Musik]
der advent ist für die einen die zeit
der ankunft für andere ist es in diesem
jahr die zeit in der sie abschied nehmen
abschied von lieb gewordenen menschen
und gewohnheiten wie jedes jahr betreibt
der förster und holzkünstler hermann
schönbächler mit seiner familie einen
stand am bieler weihnachtsmarkt das
blüht wird tödlich
schon bald werden die schönbächlers die
schweiz in richtung kanada verlassen
zeit um sich auf den abschied
vorzubereiten hatten sie bis jetzt kaum
noch mitleid
[Gelächter]
mit über 100 holzfäller hermann zieht
mit seiner familie dahin wo noch
genügend bäume stehen seit er sich
erinnern kann träumt er von einem leben
in der kanadischen wildnis und immer
wieder kreuzen leute am stand auf um
sich von herrmann und christine zu
verabschieden
[Musik]
sechs kilometer gebaut das heißt es
weiter im jahr kräftig oder eben zwei
drehtage strom irgendwie irgendwo
irgendwie ich mir das leben des marc
hermann hjalmar
[Musik]
neuland zu betreten muss nicht immer
bedeuten dass man in die weite ferne
zieht neuland zu betreten kann auch
heißen dass man dem eigenen leben eine
neue wendung verleiht
anja kind geht die betriebs ökonomin und
claude wegmann der werber wollen nach
italien auswandern
als erstes kaufen sich einen hund 2000
franken kostet der hund doch anja und
claude sind überzeugt dass sich der kauf
lohnen wird
denn in ihrer vorstellung soll der
kleine kino in den wäldern des eigenen
agriturismo bald nach kostbaren trüffeln
suchen
kann ich dir auslegen mit seinem neuen
buch heißt juno das neue
familienmitglied noch nicht welche rolle
ihm im landgasthof in italien zu kommen
wird gino macht den anfang
ihm sollen schafe pferde hirscher und
hühner folgen blut und anja haben mit
ihrem landgasthof in italien großes vor
insofern ist es für mich jetzt nicht
nichts komplett neues aber ich muss war
das früher da hat man einfach den hund
dann gehabt um sich gar nicht so damit
beschäftigt und diesmal gebe ich mir da
die gut weil das auch mein erster
eigener und ist mehr mühe um alles
richtig zu machen
ich freue mich natürlich unheimlich du
musst mir dann noch die decke geben oder
eine tausche auch hinten ja ja die hat
die war die ganze zeit in dem häuschen
wo die wahl und hat dadurch den geruch
der
ja ja der familie da das ist für ihn
dann noch so ein stück heimat multimedia
sehr auf berufsorientierung wollen wir
hoffen dass das so ist
aber ich ja schön ruhig geht irgendwie
hier beatmet
[Musik]
hoffentlich ist nicht krank
eine krankmachende fahren ja gern auf
andere nicht
ein bisschen
heute führt die reise noch nicht nach
italien sondern von chur nach horgen wo
die beiden leben hier wartet ein
weiteres familienmitglied das nach
italien mit geht anja schwester nina
nicht nur nina auch mutter gute ist in
der schweiz zu besuch und auch sie
glaubten beiden gar nichts
ich glaube roth nein
[Musik]
an der pazifikküste in südamerika leben
seit ein paar tagen ali beckstein seine
frau jenny und söhnchen sven für alli
ist es das neue zuhause für jenny eine
art heimkehr in den schoß ihrer familie
mutter sarah und bruder matteo leben und
arbeiten hier
die jungen auswanderer warten noch immer
auf den container mit ihren möbeln
der ist noch nicht in lima eingetroffen
deshalb nutzt die familie die zeit für
einen ausflug ans meer und auf den
fischmarkt der kleine sven ist mit
seinen blonden haaren und den blauen
augen der heimlichen liebling der
marktfrauen
[Applaus]
der kleine sven lernt fische kennen die
er in der schweiz noch nie gesehen habt
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
sven ist mit seinem schnäppchen
sichtlich zufrieden
die familie wettstein ist in ihrer neuen
heimat angekommen
ich habe gerne shoppen habe den moment
ich muss ein bisschen zunächst einfach
shoppen jetzt im moment noch das nicht
machen schade finde was hast du denn
deine sachen wir haben liebe
wir brauchen nichts im moment haben
da aber keine spielzeuge hat seinen
tisch
[Musik]
für viele sind es ein paar unbedeutende
zahlen auf einem stück blech für andere
ist es ein stück identität und daraus
liest sich da doch was einem die
autonummer wirklich bedeutet merkt man
oft erst wenn man sie abgeben muss vor
seiner abreise nach bali erfährt dies
auch orlando stammen an diesem
wintermorgen im engadin in zwei solch
edle sich mobilität eigentlich will
definiert hat das symbolische akt das
ist eigentlich glauben und schweizer das
sind doch stockheimer thoma da jetzt
abgeht aber dass ich gott zu führen
schließlich hat sie nicht saarland kann
man aber dass vor wenigen jahren deutete
nichts darauf hin dass anni kuhn
zusammen mit orlando stammen je nach
bali auswandern würde
beide waren verheiratet und garten
zusammen mit ihren damaligen partnern
und kindern in ihren gemeinden als
vorzeigefamilie doch tief in ihrem
innersten sei da noch etwas gewesen eine
ungestillte sehnsucht und dann lernte
anni orlando kennen und alles war
plötzlich ganz anders
und da war und er plötzlich das einfach
erwähnen tsunami eigentlich sehr gut
die zunahme ist einfach ein traum und er
ist wunderbar für euch heute kommt sie
fanden sich sie nahmen eine auszeit in
sumatra wo sie nach dem realen tsunami
für ein hilfswerk am wiederaufbau
mitwirkten und sie kamen dabei zum
schluss dass sie miteinander leben
wollten
fern der schweiz in bali
vier jahre nachdem sich anni kuhn und
orlando stamm kennen und lieben gelernt
haben machen sie ernst und wandern aus
in biel plante der förster hermann
schönbächler das künftige leben in
kanada viel länger und doch scheint
seine mutter jetzt da es so weit ist
überrascht zu sein lautet ja irgendwie
hat die schocker ankaufen um
sicherheitsdruck gmbh oebs gearbeitet
das war ja da hatten es auch etliche
ausstellungen hatte der gang mit den
klassen wie stark sie war
[Musik]
ohne angst haben zu machen wo bist du
manchmal muss man auch abschied nehmen
von menschen die noch gar nicht bereit
sind verlassen zu werden
[Musik]
es ist früh am morgen im murtal anja
kinski und claude wegmann wollen in
ihrem agriturismo in italien den gästen
der einst nicht nur trüffel sondern auch
schafskäse servieren
für heute haben sie sich eine
schnellbleiche im melken organisiert was
ihr das habe der bauer ulrich zeigt der
betriebsökonom in und dem werbe wie es
geht
[Musik]
wenn die noch um sie auf die stuttgarter
nachrichten und die ganze auch muss also
mit stroh ich musste das vorsichtig
ich glaube zur lehre wieder
damit ist der mieter so noch jede lange
reise beginnt mit dem ersten schritt und
jeder käse mit dem ersten scharf dann
kam auf 1 5 bis 2 und dann werde man
wieder relativ junge über die laune
relativ uhr dann irgendwann mal so dass
ein rückgang von der magie herausfuhr
kreis habe dankend an street firma und
der name ist ein traum drummer lassen
ich bin schon fordern
ja ich habe überhaupt keine erfahrung
mit fahrten hat mir noch nie was damit
zu tun gehabt habe auch noch nie einen
so gehalten und jagte war ganz fertig
[Musik]
und landes schlug bud neue spielkamerad
findet ina
[Musik]
ein letzter besuch in hermann
schönbächlers werkstatt in biel bevor er
seine sieben sachen dem nachfolger
übergibt muss ja nicht immer so nicht
gibt es somit 2 friedrich ani ist es für
mich eigentlich schon klar dass ich mich
lieber möchte kanada oder am rand von
zivilisation verbringen
in dicken
[Applaus]
christine zips xxi ich sehe mit ihren
familien gekommen
auswanderer die befreundete familien
besuchen denn er hat ja sie aber
eigentlich ohne anderswo nur das nicht
irgendwie froh zu denen entweder
entweder hat man das im blut
[Musik]
ali und jennifer leben seit ein paar
tagen in einem der besseren quartiere in
lima
[Musik]
hier wohnen sie direkt über janis mutter
in einer wohnung die noch fertiggestellt
werden muss die nähe zur familie bietet
raum für konflikte und stellt einen
witali auf die geduldsprobe
sie hat keine ahnung was geduld ist ja
die angestellten aber es hat noch nie
als noah worden
jennifer bringt söhnchens wenn zum
kindergarten damit sie witali zusammen
einen ersatzschlüssel zur wohnung
besorgen kann
der kleine hat sich innert weniger tage
in lima gut eingelebt
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
die tochter vor
der beschluss zu ende
die schlüsselrolle das ist mir völlig
wurscht
[Applaus]
hallo meine lieben wir haben ein kleines
problem hast du einen schlüssel für das
haupttor bei uns zu hause während jenny
achten schlüssel wartet begrüßt ali
seine neue familie
[Musik]
das ist mir sch
und so lernte berner börse wettstein im
fernen lima unfreiwillig und tag für tag
was geduld heißt
[Musik]
in der schweiz ist es zur gleichen zeit
nach winter und doch wird es hermann
schönbächler warm ums herz
denn für ihn und seine familie ist heute
der große tag habt nach kanada auch
hermanns mutter elisabeth schönbächler
ist mit zum flughafen kloten gereist um
sich zu verabschieden
[Gelächter]
so groß sei
[Musik]
columbo
ja
[Musik]
ich war
wurde
[Musik]
erstmals seit sie das anwesen im letzten
herbst gekauft haben reisen claude und
anja mit und gino in ihr neues heim nach
italien rom china
guck mal irgendwelche fremden ihr hause
einfach nicht aus gehen wir hinten
gucken ob es war so meister nein das hat
was strom
das habe man aber wohl auch die kahle
für respekt jahre lang hat hier niemand
gewohnt der vorbesitzer ein engländer
hat das haus unaufgeräumt verlassen sehr
zur freude von gino dem trüffel und
erste von stück von simon riesen wurst
ja das scheint hier das ist doch auch
hier kommt matratze auf punkt und komma
[Musik]
sonst können wir noch punkten heute
nacht des 30
ja müde er ein langer tag wird so
schnell wie möglich das hier
einigermaßen schlafen kann einfach mal
so die ersten acht
[Applaus]
mein baby los schluss
[Musik]
ja das ganze stadt orlando stamm und
aniko sagen heute adieu
auf sie warten 16 stunden flug nach bali
mit umsteigen in singapur
manchmal braucht es im leben einen
abschied damit man endlich zueinander
finden kann
erstmals überhaupt sind alle kinder von
anni und orlando an einem ort vereint
die vier söhne von anni sind zum teil
von weit her angereist um ihre mutter
ein letztes mal für lange zeit zu sehen
und auch woanders tochter und sein sohn
sind da ein familientreffen das zeigt
wie außergewöhnlich anis und orlandos
liebesgeschichte ist
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
zwei manager ist vital aktiv dafür alles
klimaskeptiker
juristen abschied
[Musik]
franken
und was macht also andere aufmacht
falsche
glaubs
voßkuhle
funkuhr
[Musik]
in mittelitalien liegt san martino hier
haben anja und claude die erste nacht
auf der luftmatratze gut überstanden
schon während des frühstücks
organisieren sie ihr neues leben
dann erst mal als touristen anmelden und
und mit anderen worten es kann gut sein
dass die uns dann irgendwie dann doch
noch von irgendwelchen problemen
erzählen und das war dann nochmal
unverrichteter dinge abziehen müssen
denke ich okay danke macht's gut
also für michael mind jetzt es gebe eben
unterschiedliche möglichkeiten uns
anzumelden und die einfachste wäre
eigentlich dass wir uns als touristen
anmelden
also ich würde sagen wir fahren jetzt
einfach mal hin und probieren das und er
sagt auch wir können das ganze entspannt
angehen heute mal die ganzen infos holen
um beim nächsten mal wirklich alle
papiere was er uns jetzt sagen
na gut dann gucken was machst du mit
meinem schluss spannend in feisabad anja
und claude haben sich vor drei jahren
kennengelernt
die deutsche und der schweizer haben
schnell gemerkt dass sie ähnliche
vorstellungen von der zukunft haben
beide träumten sie von einem landgasthof
in italien für das anwesen haben sie
einen mittleren sechsstelligen betrag
bezahlt sagen sie
nach der renovation werde ihr traum über
eine million franken gekostet haben
doch heute müssen sie sich erstmal auf
der gemeinde um eine
aufenthaltsbewilligung bemühen
hier beginnt der kampf mit der
italienischen bürokratie und weil claude
kaum italienisch spricht muss anja
diesen part übernehmen
na ja wenn du willst aber es wird ja
vorhin ist eine große tombola via roma
nur die latte
[Musik]
behauptung das geht ja schon gut los
hatte eine eine bis eineinhalb stunden
sie stiegen mit david kommen in kanada
endlich nach einem langen flug bis
vancouver ist die familie schönbächler
jetzt seit zwei tagen im auto unterwegs
weiter richtung norden
die letzte größere stadt haben sie
längst hinter sich gelassen
jetzt sind sie kurz vor dem ziel
[Musik]
und das sehen sie nächste woche
die schönbächlers sind in ihrer neuen
heimat auf den spuren der bären
wiedersehen mit einem stück helvetischen
möbeldesigns in lima versuchen sich
jenny und arles wettstein in der
gastronomie
[Musik]
in italien ist der weg zum landgasthof
steinig claude und anja erkennen dass
sie noch sehr viel arbeiten müssen bis
sie her gäste empfangen können
während in bali bereits die dächer
gedeckt werden ein besuch im
ferienparadies
dies alles und mehr in der nächsten
folge von auf und davon
[Musik]